public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fera tous clémentine autain est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bon soir
dans ça vous êtes soutien de jean luc
mélenchon candidate aux législatives en
seine saint denis porte parole du
mouvement ensemble
bienvenue dans ce rendez vous politique
de public sénat de la rose professe des
échos et de radio classique
trois grandes questions pour vous ce
soir la première vous sera posée par
charlotte gauthier de radio classique
sur la crédibilité du programme
économique de jean luc mélenchon lucide
malandain d'une agence france presse
vous interrogera sur ce duel entre jean
luc mélenchon et benoît hamon ou est-ce
que ça va pas conduire la gauche dans le
mur
et puis troisième question n'a rien eu
là par dorian mancini de public sénat le
dégagisme mot d'ordre on a entendu de
jean luc mélenchon est ce que ça peut
faire une politique en soit voilà le
programme
on va commencer d'abord par une question
d'actualité
clémentine autain on a appris donc la
démission de bruno le roux pour des
contrats qu'ils avaient passé notamment
avec les filles âgées de 15 ans à
l'époque collaboratrice à l'assemblée
nationale notamment
vous avez été surpris par cette affaire
encore eu encore une
c'est vrai que chaque matin on allume
notre radio on ouvre les journaux et il
ya des nouvelles de cette nature qui qui
je crois blesse beaucoup la démocratie
il a bien fait de démissionner bien sûr
qu'il a bien fait de démissionner c'est
un minimum
finir ce quinquennat avec un minimum de
dignité c'est est ce qu'on demandait à
ceux à ce ministre donc oui il a bien
faire après le problème reste entier
parce que c'est pas la faire d'un homme
on le voit bien les affaires se suivent
et malheureusement se ressemblent donc
c'est le système institutionnel qui
aujourd'hui et est à bout de souffle et
il faut impérativement de nouvelles
règles démocratiques pour en finir avec
ces affaires alors je vous propose de
passer à la première grande question
qu'ils aillent qui va vous être posée
par charlotte gauthier de radio
classique
on va s'intéresser au programme
économique de jean luc mélenchon va donc
appelé charles gautier si elle veut bien
venir jusqu'à nous
[Musique]
charles gautier bonsoir bonsoir michael
bonsoir clémentine autain votre question
alors en matière d'économie on a un peu
envie de vous poser une question
clémentine autain est ce que le
programme de jean luc mélenchon et
crédible je ne m'explique
est ce qu'on peut vraiment être candidat
à la présidence de la république et
prévoir une augmentation de la dette
jusqu'à 116 % du pib
avec 273 milliards d'euros de dépenses
ont donc fait sourire oui ça me fait
sourire parce que ce qui creuse la dette
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont les
gouvernements successifs et vous n'avez
qu'à regarder le cas de la grèce pour
voir que les cures d'austérité il y en a
eu plus de 9 en grèce ont produit qua
non seulement un désastre social
magistral en grèce des inégalités qui se
sont creusés de la récession économique
est en bout de course quoi un creusement
de la dette
donc je pense que le programme le plus
crédible est justement celui de jean luc
mélenchon parce qu'il propose une
relance par l'activité qui est de nature
à faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses et à diminuer en bout de course
la dette donc je pense qu'il est au
contraire le plus solide le plus
cohérent pour résorber la dette il veut
financer tout ça par des hausses
d'impôts les les français subissent déjà
un ras-le-bol fiscal est ce que n'avait
pas peur que le sentiment de matraquage
fiscal soient renforcés tout en
augmentant le smic a mené 326 euros
en généralisant la sixième semaine de
congés payés que les français ont rempli
avec matraques et par l'augmentation du
smic sérieuse de toutes offres au feu
l'augmentation du smic ça va donner de
l'air à beaucoup de français qui
n'arrivent pas à finir les feuilles
l'augmentation des impôts elle doit bien
avoir lieu un moment pour finir oui mais
la question l'augmentation des impôts
c'est qu'ils ont taxe sait où on prend
l'argent je vous parlais des 80
milliards de l'évasion fiscale mais je
peux aussi vous parler des 40 milliards
du cic eux qui ont été données aux
grandes entreprises sans aucune
contrepartie en matière d'emploi donc
c'est une question d'orientation et de
choix politiques nous nous voulons
investir dans le partage des richesses
taxer le capital
la rente faire en sorte que la réforme
fiscale soit plus juste parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les classes
moyennes qui paie le plus d'impôts
proportionnellement nous avons cinq
tranches aujourd'hui nous proposons d'en
faire 14 de telle sorte que il est un
lissage qui permettent justement d'avoir
un impôt plus juste
donc ce sont des mesures tout simplement
de justice sociale et je crois que ce
dont on n'a plus les moyens aujourd'hui
c'est de payer les salaires des grands
dirigeants c'est de payer la rente
je vous donnais un seul chiffre mais qui
est l'augmentation des bénéfices en plus
exactement de ce qui a été reversée aux
en dividendes en 2010 sept ans d'un seul
coup évidemment j'avais décidé de
prendre quelques chiffres mais ça n'est
pas très grave
en tout cas ils ont explosé voilà
cinquante sept milliards d'euros de
dividendes 57 milliards d'euros de
dividendes ont été distribués en 2016
aux entreprises du cac40 donc vous
prédire un record depuis 2007
il faut l'entendre et moi j'ai discuté
il ya encore quelques jours avec je
prends cet exemple là parce que celui
qui me vient en tête
claudine qui est caissière dans un
supermarché simply à villepinte
elle a trente cinquante boutiques 35 ans
qu'elle est caissière à la 1300 euros
nets de revenus vous trouvez siège de la
question c'est la question du chocolat
bien compris et notamment des salaires
moi je voudrais vous sortent des
salaires et pendant ce temps là j'en
entends qui nous disent que les députés
devraient être augmentés à 9000 euros du
vainqueur
donc non mais écoutez et puis quoi
encore que il y a eu et il y a eu r
france non mais attendez à air france où
il propose des restructurations
les dirigeants ont eu le culot de
s'augmenter et pas de s'augmenter un peu
de se monter considérablement
donc c'est cette répartition des
richesses qui se fait aujourd'hui au
profit des plus puissants que nous
voulons en effet remettre en question
donc je ne crois pas que ce sera un
matraquage pour la majorité des français
mais au contraire un mouvement qui va
permettre de mieux vivre et de mieux
vivre pour le grand nombre la retraite à
60 ans c'est une proposition jean luc
mélenchon c'est également une
proposition de marine le pen
comme vous le savez c'est un de leurs
points communs mais ce n'est pas le seul
l'abrogation de la loi comrie le
protectionnisme économique
on en vient à se demander si dans le sur
ces sujets ils sont pas un peu des faux
frères finalement politique jean-luc
mélenchon à marine le pen
c'est votre question me heurte
profondément parce qu' il peut y avoir
quelques points ici et là mais le projet
global de jean luc mélenchon est
totalement opposé au projet global de
marine le pen
et cette petite musique qui consiste à
dire regardez c'est les deux extrêmes
ils sont dangereux etc où l'on danse
musique et mon île natale
que ce que veut dire mais c'est vous qui
la fait de la petite mise à feu doux à
oui oui je pense que c'est c'est vous
qui la fenêtre parfois l'expérience call
électorat qui vote éventuellement marine
le pen peut se rabattre sur mélenchon ou
inversement c'est qu'il y a des points
qui leur sont communs rejoint dans ces
matches là je pense qu'il y a je ne
cherche pas ce qui est commun avec
marine le pen
vous comprenez que dans l'histoire y
compris entre sa famille politique est
la nôtre il ya même eu parfois du sang
sur les mains
nous sommes profondément opposé marine
le pen suggère de diviser les français
c'est son projet politique
elle est pour l'ordre moral elle est
autoritaire sur le plan démocratique
nous nous voulons au contraire plus de
pouvoir aux citoyens aux salariés dans
l'entreprise nous ne voulons pas nous
refermer sur nous-mêmes mais au
contraire nous ouvrir nous avons un
projet de solidarité et nous voulons
rassembler les français tous les
français le projet d' emmanuel macron
c'est le même que françois fillon entre
médecins la même échelle je pense que
sans doute la violence du projet n'est
pas de même force
il y en a un qui veut supprimer cinq
cent mille fonctionnaires l'autre qu'il
venant supprimer que 120 milles mais je
dirais qu'en tendance il s'agit quand
même de prolonger trente années de
politiques néolibérales dont on voit le
résultat vous savez que sarkozy plus
françois hollande sur dix ans voilà le
résultat
c'est un chômeur toutes les trois
minutes voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est
un coût qui peut aujourd'hui avec
emmanuel masson se serait encore des
chômeurs tout les trois milieux mais je
pense que le projet politique qui est le
sien si tant est qu'on puisse bien le
comprendre parce que moi je l'écoutais
pendant trois heures et demie hier le
débat l'ossature la cohérence politique
de manuel mâcon est à même pas très très
nettes mais j'ai pris le temps de lire
son livre est ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que les solutions concrètes qu'il
souhaite apporter
vous avez aimé la loi elle conneries
vous avez aimé le cic mais vous allez
adorer le mandat des manuels macron donc
tout ce qui se raconte que l'on va voter
macron là pour éviter le pire mais on
verra après pour refonder un projet qui
permette d'améliorer nos vies
de reconstruire une espérance de gauche
à mon avis font fausse route
parce que le danger est grand de voir un
projet de même nature que celui que nous
avons depuis 30 ans à devenir et au
final une extrême droite qui continue de
rêver sur un autre point important du
programme de jean luc mélenchon celui de
l'europe
il explique au vu de son programme que
s'il est élu il désobéira au traité de
l'union européenne
ça veut dire quoi en fait ça signifie
qu'il est pour un freak site c'est
quelque chose que vous envisagez vous
même parce que des objets retraités ça a
des conséquences
moi je suis pour que nous ayons un
projet européen qui tienne la route et
qui donne envie aux français et à
l'ensemble des peuples d'europe d'être
ensemble et ceux qui aujourd'hui sont en
train de menacer le projet européen
c'est ceux qui mènent ces politique de
dumping social c'est-à-dire de
concurrence entre les salariés
d'austérité et donc quand on dit
l'austérité c'est quoi c'est vous
parliez de la dette tout à l'heure c'est
très très concrets pour les gens ça veut
dire comment vous voulez avoir de bons
services publics du transport comment
voulez vous avoir des médecins et des
hôpitaux qui fonctionnent bien des
écoles avec des professeurs en nombre de
qualité comment voulez-vous à lèvres
avoir cette protection sociale ses
droits cette qualité de vie dès lors que
partout on baisse ce qui est mis en
commun donc cette europe là est une
europe qui va dans le mur donc ce que
nous voulons c'est une serre ciel
manière sauver l'europe en lui redonnant
du sens et ce sens et celui de la
solidarité de la sortie du modèle
néolibéral de la sortie de l'austérité
c'est ça que nous voulons
on va passer la deuxième grosse question
merci charlotte on va passer cette fois
à la gauche si vous voulez bien ce match
entre benoît hamon et jean luc mélenchon
qui a gagné il épreuve de vérité avec la
fp
d'un jour notre partenaire de votre
question du style alors dans le duel à
mon mélenchon qui prend le kiki prend la
première place si j'ose dire
est ce que ce duel ne va pas entraîner
la gauche dans le mur je regrette
d'abord que n'est pas un rassemblement
possible de la gauche
l'auriez souhaité aujourd'hui j'aurais
souhaité à la condition évidemment qu'il
soit sur un cap clair qu'ils soient un
cap dissociée de la politique
gouvernementale
moi je veux dire le rassemblement je
suis pour le rassemblement la division
qui peut être pour la division je
préfère l'unité
je préfère le rassemblement mais à la
condition qu'il nous amène vers une voie
différente de celle qui a été menée
depuis cinq ans comprenait ce qui s'est
passé cinquante deux quinquennats
hollande valls
vous avez un front national qui est
passé de 17 à 27
vous avez un pays qui est totalement
désorienté politiquement parce qu' un
gouvernement qui s'est dit gauche a mené
une politique de droite et le peuple qui
est aujourd'hui désespérés mais ça fait
beaucoup comme bilan prix mais que peut
notamment être comptable je pense que la
victoire de benoît hamon est une très
belle nouvelle pour la gauche parce que
le peuple de gauche comme on dit c'est
mobiliser dans la primaire de la belle
alliance populaire pour envoyer un
message au gouvernement et pour le
sanctionner et pour dire il faut une
nouvelle voie donc cette victoire est
une bonne nouvelle mais se trouve que le
la temporalité c'est-à-dire le moment où
nous est arrivé cette primaire a été
très tardive et donc c'était fait pour
françois hollande
c'était un calendrier chrono 1 vous
rendez compte on est le moment où il est
désigné on est à quelques semaines du
dépôt légal facto pour pour discuter
pour dialoguer c'était compliqué et moi
j'avais plaidé milliard maintenant un
certain temps pour que nous ayons une
primaire de tous ceux qui avaient
contesté la politique gouvernementale
créée il y aurait les frondeurs il y
aurait eu europe écologie avec le volant
et alors là
mais les frondeurs aussi n'ont pas
accepté ils ont voulu la primaires de
toute la gauche c'est voyez le résultat
avec la nouvelle majorité quand même ce
qu'on a appelé certains termes je sais
qui leur plaît pas trop mais ce qu'on a
appelé les frondeurs plaidé en ce sens
donc il ya une primaire je vois que
manuel valls ailleurs trahi le résultat
il a dit qu'il soutenait puis soutien
plus enfin c'est quand même bon jean luc
mélenchon a pour lui la cohérence dont
la durée et je pense qu'ils affichent
aujourd'hui un cap qui est un cap clair
cela n'empêche pas de penser à la suite
et de se dire que la victoire de benoît
hamon
les propositions et moi hier j'ai écouté
il y avait des convergences andré benoît
hamon qui suit les gens vont vous posez
la suite avant le premier tour est ce
que sont les réseaux cela 19 rassemble
avant le premier cas écoutez là où je
crois que je ne s'est fini c'est terminé
je pense que c'est terminé depuis le
moment où d'ailleurs eu dans les
sondages par exemple le dab à écouter si
on a un je ne sais pas si pour l'instant
on ne sait pas tout à fait ce qui est en
train de se passer est maintenant si je
ne peux pas faire de la politique
fiction sur ce qui va se passer
ce que je sais c'est qu'on avait pas de
méthode pour dire lequel des deux devait
se retirer que par ailleurs on n'avait
pas le temps pour discuter de compromis
nécessaires il faut gagner il faut se
rassembler mais il faut le faire pour
mener une autre politique sinon on
désespère plus encore si on n'est pas
capable d'avoir une proposition qui
qu'ils soient claires regardez-moi je
vais prendre un exemple concret la
candidature de myriam el khomri bon
c'est elle qui a fait la loi commun
contre laquelle le peuple de gauche
c'est pas des millions aux élections
législatives en 18 ans face à caroline
de haas bon je me demande si c'est
maintenant même sur ce plateau benoît
hamon lui dit mais alors qui de myriam
el khomri ou de caroline de haas qui est
des figures du combat contre la loi et
comrie qui choisissez vous est pris
soutiendrez-vous benoît hamon n'est pas
en capacité de répondre
il ne le peut pas parce qu'il est le
candidat du parti socialiste etc mais ce
flou là il est concret parce que une
fois que vous aurez une majorité
parlementaire
il va bien savoir dans quel sens oui
mais vous allons être que là on voit
bien ça s'égrènent tous les jours les
les anciens ministres et ses parts chez
macron de plus en plus c'est font
défection leysen président nous c'est
une belle valse parce que nous l'avons
dit je pense qu'on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui rassembler ceux qui ont
soutenu cette politique gouvernementale
et ceux qui l'ont combattu mais là on
est devant un contexte où la gauche pour
l'instant est éliminé du deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle vous prenez
acte emmanuel macron n'est pas de gauche
on y propose deux questions simples à
tout jamais dans notre question chantage
et décidé de droite ni de gauche - de
droite et de gauche donc voilà oui donc
état dans l'instant la gauche tels que
voulait incarner aujourd'hui ou tel que
benoît hamon là car elle est éliminée
d'abord je pense qu'il faut pas donner
les résultats avant l'élection ben voilà
la wii les faisons un petit peu
attention parce qu'avec les sondages
voilà vous sont le pomper et vous allez
quand même la moitié des électeurs qui
aujourd'hui se trouve dans une situation
d' indécision total donc je suis pas
pour qu'on juste reine qu'elle et
prennent des décisions un moment donné
uniquement au vu des sondages ne pas se
poser la question du vote utile aux gens
dit qu' il incarne aujourd'hui ce vote
utile moi je pense que le vote utile
aujourd'hui c'est le vote de conviction
qu'on est las de voter sans arrêt contre
de voter par dépit de voter j'ai
beaucoup arrivent pas autre chose
les actions proposées avec avec ses
convictions oui je le crois profondément
vous êtes candidate aux élections
législatives à sevran tremblay 20 ans
commence alan salzman sur le terrain et
commencent à ce pas justement je vais
interroger plus spécifiquement avec la
france insoumise qui pour l'instant a
organisé ses propres qui est mouvement
de jean luc mélenchon pardon connu
autour de sa candidature qui pour
l'instant fait c'est propre investiture
est-ce que vous avez par exemple dans
votre circonscription un candidat france
insoumise
on ne vous étonnez pas de candidat
france insoumise contre moi mais vous
avez raison de pointer ce problème qui
concerne d'autres circonscriptions et
pour ma part je souhaite que nous ayons
aux élections législatives des
candidatures par tous rassemblés de
toute cette gauche qui a contesté la
politique gouvernementale pendant cinq
ans et qui souhaite ouvrir une voie
nouvelle à gauche est en tout cas mon
mouvement politique et moi
personnellement je regrette pour cette
unité la division serait totalement
mortifère mais je ne peux pas imaginer
dans l'est que nous trouvions pas une
solution pour avoir culture
les solutions qui nous portent le plus
haut dans les discussions avec la france
insoumise bien de cela il connaît la
même manière que les discussions se
passaient au sein du front de gauche en
2002 bien sûr et d'ailleurs je regrette
qu'ils de son dieu qui est plus trompe
pas c'était quand même un cadre glock
c'était quand même un cadre qui nous
permettait justement de justice qui
bloque aujourd'hui
alors là je vous prends deux heures si
vous voulez un maximum de minutes je
peut pas résumer parce que depuis cinq
ans il ya différents moments où les
choses se sont mal emmanchée pour le
dire simplement aux salles au sein du
front de gauche je pense qu'on a fait
l'erreur de ne pas accepter les
adhésions directes
après la la campagne présidentielle
législatives de 2012
enfin il ya eu il ya eu calif il ya eu
des différences stratégiques à des
moments donnés et donc on est arrivé à
un point où ce cartel n'a plus vraiment
fonctionné on est sur une nouvelle
dynamique
on a une présidentielle maintenant dans
quelques semaines il faut la réussir
nous y avons tous intérêt et j'appelle
de mes voeux à la responsabilité
collective de telle sorte que nous ayons
pour les législatives
les dynamiques encore une fois les plus
rassembleuse et les plus forts pour une
vraie non non non ça ne ressemble pas un
voeu pieux ça ressemble à date
détermination des relations entre pierre
le roux jean luc mélenchon paquin sont
plutôt détériorées ce coup qui
regardaient ça un petit peu peut-être
n'a pas de côté pour nous en parler un
petit peu je pense encore une fois qu'il
ya une histoire récente où il ya eu des
blessures réciproque et des divergences
stratégiques ou tactique etc
donc on a on a eu ces difficultés là
elles sont sans doute devant nous mais
je suis pour faire attention dans les
semaines qui viennent a pas mettre de
l'eau au moulin mais au contraire à
avoir un discours de rassemblement et à
être je dirais à la hauteur de la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre que la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon soit
la plus haute possible au soir du
premier tour
eco législatives et je pense que bien
sûr que la france a soumises doit
entendre ce que je dis
et le parti communiste également des
responsabilités partagées et peut-être
nous aussi de mon mouvement je suis
toujours prête à prendre ma part mais je
pense qu'à un moment donné quand on est
au pied du mur faut trouver des
solutions sinon on n'est pas à vue lors
du défilé de samedi entre bastille et la
république que pierre laurent était
certes dans le carré de tête m'enfin
très loin les communistes ont lancé une
campagne autonome avec un programme
autonome tout en soutenant jean luc
mélenchon c'est tenable tout ça c'est
compréhensible mais c'est pas le
scénario le plus souhaitable si c'est ça
que vous voulez m'entendre dire je pense
qu'à l'avenir il faut qu'on trouve le
moyen de travailler mieux ensemble
ça c'est absolument clair le retour
d'expérience oui voilà voilà
mais mais là on est dans une bataille de
quatre semaines comprenez le bien pour
que notre candidat ait le meilleur score
donc je je je fais l'appel au
rassemblement et vous inquiétez pas on
aura tout le temps ensuite de discuter
sur la forme d'organisation souhaita
pour les années à venir merci et merci
beaucoup
on va accueillir à présent oriane monde
fini on va parler des institutions et la
6ème république
[Musique]
bonsoir organes ont servi qu à l on sert
qu'à 26 notamment ça alors vous allez
nous parler de la sixième république
dans un instant mais on a entendu
beaucoup parler d'un mot place de la
république samedi c'était le fameux
dégagé
c'était beaucoup repris dans la foule
écoutez ce que disait jean luc mélenchon
place de la république samedi
il faut que les bulletins de vote
donnent le coup de balai qu'il est par
tous sans exception dégagé
[Applaudissements]
il ya un nouveau qu'est née après
résistance
j'ai dégagé vous entendez oui j'ai
entendu samedi oui comment avez vous
réagi en entendant cette phrase c'est
pas la première fois que je l'entends
c'est pas mon vocabulaire c'est pas ma
façon de m'exprimer mais j'entends dans
cette ce mot d'ordre qu'il y a tout
simplement une aspiration au
renouvellement
il faut l'entendre comme tel c'est à
dire que l'exaspération que nous
ressentons que ressentent la majorité de
nos concitoyens en écoutant la radio la
télé aujourd'hui c'est quand même qu'on
en a ras-le-bol de ce qu'on appelle le
système d'ailleurs le terme lui-même
très à la mode et fait beaucoup débat
donc on en a marre d'aller jusqu'à
employer le mot de dégagisme dégagisme
est ce que ce n'est pas un monde
dangereux
je n'aime pas ce terme je voulais dit
c'est en tout cas c'est pas mon terme
mais je veux entendre ce que ce terme
exprime du point de vue des militants
est ce que cela exprime c'est qu'il faut
passer une nouvelle république qu'on a
un besoin de renouvellement que nous
proposons cette nouvelle république avec
des mesures fortes qui sont aussi bien
le statut de l'élu le non cumul des
mandats la proportionnelle la
reconnaissance n'est pas ce terme est
est ce que il a le droit de l'employé
aujourd'hui qu'ils oriane c'est quelque
chose de dangereux qui fait peur qui
fait un peu populiste à bout ces peurs
un jeu sans cette idée de la part d'un
candidat à la présidence de la
république d'employés en termes comme ça
dégagisme je pense qu'il fait référence
à des mouvements qui ont existé ailleurs
à travers le monde et qui qui appellent
en effet un changement de régime
politique et pensait que les français
sont prêts à un discours aussi radical
je pense que les français sont en
attente d'un discours un peu radical et
d'un changement véritable sage le projet
de mouvement que je mets pas lorsque
quoi donald trump
oui face à donald trump non je pensais
pas à donald trump ou ailleurs je
pensais au printemps
non je pense au printemps arabe je pense
que ce qui s'est passé aussi en amérique
latine face ce sont des modernes ce qui
s'est passé autour d'eux des indignés en
espagne vous avez à travers le monde
un mouvement assez fort qui prend
évidemment qui a et qui ne touchera pas
le même bien sûr qui touche la france et
qui n'est pas le même qui n'a pas les
formes d'expression suivant les
histoires des pays des continents mais
qui atteint l'europe
aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec la grèce on
l'a vu avec l'espagne et en france il ya
quelque chose de cette de cette nature
là et le
problème c'est que cette demande de
radicalité cette exaspération cette
colère et ce qu'elle va aller du côté
d'une réponse à la donald trump du repli
de la xénophobie de l'autoritarisme
ou est ce qu'elle va aller du côté de
l'émancipation du partage des richesses
et d'une nouvelle république que je joue
et c'est ça le débat se jouer sur ce
discours jouer sus trémosa ne renforce
pas le sentiment de tous pourris et donc
chez nous renforcer le front national
nous devons répondre aux besoins de
changement véritable
il ya eu des alternances depuis trente
ans un coup à gauche un coup à droite un
coup à gauche un coup à droite les
français en tout cas moi je les entends
dans ma circonscription mais je crois
que vous les entendez peut-être
j'imagine j'espère de la même manière se
disent mais à quoi ça sert on a toujours
la même politique
et si nous ne prenons pas la mesure de
cette exaspération alors oui le pire
peut advenir lesquels et c'est notre
responsabilité à gauche d'être à niveau
de ce besoin de changement et de
radicalité c'est quoi le mot radicalité
c'est prendre à la racine des problèmes
s'est arrêtée de de faire d'eux des
petites mesurettes toujours dans le même
sens et qui finalement ne change pas la
donne
et quelle est la légitimité la
crédibilité de jean luc mélenchon qui a
parlementaire depuis 1986 de porter un
tel discours de vouloir donner un coup
de balai d'abord il a rompu avec le
parti socialiste à un moment donné ce
désaccord passent un temps en tout cas
un acte politique
un acte politique fort et moi je retiens
surtout le mouvement général les forces
politiques qui sont avec lui et qui
exige des propositions concrètes dans
cette nouvelle république je vous en
dirai sur le non-cumul la
proportionnelle etc qui concerne aussi
d'autres domaines pour une justice
indépendante la question des médias
on n'en parle pas assez mais il faudrait
une loi contre la concentration pour
davantage de pluralisme et il faut
renforcer l'aide à la presse c'est très
important une démocratie elle respire
aussi dans son plan social dans les
entreprises il faut donner davantage de
pouvoirs aux salariés dans un moment où
au contraire on a on n'arrête pas de les
empêcher d'une certaine manière de
donner leurs voix et le chômage de masse
et la précarité aujourd'hui empêche
cette démocratie sociale d'être réalité
une démocratie
clémentine autain elle est aussi forte
de ses institutions la colonne
vertébrale
le programme de jean luc mélenchon c'est
de passer à la 6ème république
est ce que ce n'est pas dangereux dans
la période actuelle de toucher aux
institutions puisqu'il serait
inconséquent est fou c'est de ne pas y
toucher
rendez compte de la défiance qui
existent aujourd'hui à l'égard dû
système institutionnel le l'abstention
qui ne cesse de grimper
le dégoût qu'ils expriment beaucoup de
nos concitoyens à l'égard de la vie
politique et vous pensez que le plus
important c'est de sauvegarder la
séquence est à la sixième république ça
va résoudre le problème de l'abstention
je pense que c'est une condition sine
qua none pour dire regardez on a compris
quelque chose ne tourne pas rond dans ce
pays on recommence et ont défini de
nouvelles bases un nouveau contrat un
retour de tahiti est une condition
sinequanone me semble-t-il pour
retrouver de la confiance entre les
électeurs les électrices les citoyennes
et citoyens et leurs représentants mais
pas simplement leurs représentants les
médias la justice
moi j'avais une question vous entende on
sait que par le tirage au sort effectué
ce week-end emmanuel macron dans un
journal n'a présenté son programme sur
la défense il y avait une question qui
lui était posée savoir si le terme
populiste lui déplaisait lui le dit ça
peut fonctionner est ce que si je dis
que ce programme est populiste ça vous
déplaît
le terme c'est un vrai débat ce terme de
populisme il retrouve aujourd'hui des
théories fort différentes
donc moi je n'utilise pas ce terme là
pour autant je sais qu'il est utilisé
par un certain nombre de personnes pour
au fond critiquer tous ceux qui
prétendent défendre le peuple et les
intérêts du grand nombre donc j'ai pas
populiste il est quoi populaire
populaire en tout cas il défend les
intérêts du peuple de ceux qui
aujourd'hui payent le prix fort des
polyphonies des plans d'austérité et et
néo libéral po clis n'est pas le terme
que moi je reprendrai mais encore une
fois je me méfie parce que ceux qui
aujourd'hui stigmatise jean luc
mélenchon ou d'autres avec ce terme là
sont souvent des personnes qui n'ont pas
la fibre de l'intérêt du grand nombre
l'autre réforme importante du prime de
jean luc mélenchon c'est le droit de
révocation des élus
là aussi sur quelle base les citoyens
vont pouvoir évoquer leurs élus alors ça
c'est une grande question je pense que
ça ça doit rester dans le cas dans leur
tête c'est dans
le programme mais la question de la
révocabilité c'est dire abandonner si un
élu fait des fautes graves ne tient pas
ses engagements qui est une possibilité
en réalité de lui dire bon bah stop ça
se termine pas au boulot et bruno le
roux il aurait été concernés par cette
mesure
baldé ministre oui la député louis oui
sans doute
n'est ce pas exactement je ne sais pas
exactement comment ça très beau kabylité
fonctionnerait je sais que c'est une
mesure qui tient beaucoup à la france
dans la france insoumise fin qui est une
mesure forte pour ma part je pense que
il faut qu'on commence d'abord sur ce
qui crée du lien
voyez ce que je veux dire ce qui crée de
la confiance mesure pas d'abord de la
mission du programme de jean luc
mélenchon ce n'est pas poussé les élus à
la démagogie la démagogie avoir la
démagogie qu'est ce que vous appelez
démagogie faire des réformes peut plus
faire des réformes qui plaisent aux
peuples qui est bas mais une sont
impopulaires pardonne mais ne pas être
évoqué pardonnez moi de vous dire une
chose mais par les temps qui courent ce
que je trouve incroyable c'est que vous
avez transformé le courage pour des
hommes politiques qui sont des hommes
politiques qui mènent des politiques
contre le peuple et donc si le courage
c'est d'être impopulaires je suis en
désaccord avec lui les gouvernants ont
le devoir d'être populaire et c'est pas
de la démagogie c'est de faire des
mesures dans lesquelles peuvent se
retrouver ceux qui souffrent aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui vous nous dites sans
arrêt que le courage serait de mener des
mesures contre le peuple et bien moi je
te promets un gouvernement où eux-mêmes
révoquer le président de la république l
autorité peut avoir un président de la
république qui à cette épée de damoclès
au-dessus de la tête
en 30 secondes mais d'abord on veut en
finir avec le président de la république
donc comme ça il aura pas le l'épée de
damoclès pendant deux heures et on peut
la considérer de damoclès voilà moi ma
logique n'est pas celle de la
révocabilité mais celle du lien
conference qui est un lien de confiance
qui doit être restaurée renouvelé
aujourd'hui le pire serait de rester en
l'état ça c'est absolument pas possible
donc voilà c'est ça la réponse la plus
importe que tu veux par une dernière
question on a appris évidemment le dff
aujourd'hui d'henri emmanuelli
c'est une certaines figures de gauche
qui disparaît oui c'est une figure du
socialisme français c'est triste moi
j'ai été triste en apprenant à nous
prenons sa mort il a il a incarné une
certaine comment dire dignité quand même
dans
c'est un homme de conviction moi j'ai
partagé notamment une bataille avec lui
qui était celle du non au traité
constitutionnel européen et je me
souviens bien de meetings ou où il y
avait de la joie de vivre à ce moment là
dans cette bataille là qu'on a qu'on a
gagné donc voilà je suis triste oui
effectivement
merci beaucoup que je retiens de tas
d'avoir été l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité merci ariane merci on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine bonne fenêtre
[Musique]